esta mañana los ataques dan un respiro y
junto con otros habitantes de origen
lugo espera la llegada de ayuda
humanitaria
yo decidí quedarme y mi esposo también
está en contra de irse sea lo que sea
esté preparado para nosotros no se puede
evitar esta población tenía 14.000
habitantes ha pasado a ser la última
bajo control ucraniano en esta área al
sur de la provincia de sap orilla las
fuerzas rusas están a pocos kilómetros
quienes se quedaron aprovechan las horas
del día para abastecerse de provisiones
porque dicen que necesitamos
libertadores de que debemos ser
liberados
cada uno intenta sobrellevar las
dificultades de la guerra a su manera no
pasan hambre pero muchos productos han
desaparecido y el dinero también los
cajeros no funcionan y los precios han
aumentado al menos un 30 por ciento
están tratando de tomarse el pueblo
nuestros muchachos no los dejarán entrar
por eso el centro de la ciudad y sus
perímetros están siendo atacados
los animales
atacaron en un sector conocido como la
fábrica la gente está huyendo detrás de
la estación de tren
este es el área residencial al que se
refiere dos mil a dos personas murieron
en el apartamento de sergei pocas cosas
han quedado intactas
atacaron este lugar y después de eso
todos los habitantes se fueron los
corredores están vacíos pero muchos no
quieren irse ni pueden hacerlo la
mayoría son personas mayores una cuenta
que no tiene a donde llevar a su madre
de 86 años
grupos de voluntarios intentan ayudarlos
una de ellas es valentina que nació en
1941 una semana después de comenzará la
segunda guerra mundial
su madre el abandono muy pequeña esta
guerra la encuentra sola de nuevo todos
los suyos ha muerto
me preguntan valentina petrona vas a
abandonar el lugar y yo digo dónde voy a
ir a abandonar el lugar para el sótano
tomaré mi carreta llevaré mis cosas
la resistencia de origen comienza por
los mayores que tienen que enfrentarse
nuevamente a una guerra